good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy monday let's acknowledge the space
that we're in it is monday
it is a full week after a short week but
you know what
we're going to rise we're going to grind
we're going to power through we're going
to make this week our
[ __ ] and then we'll be done yeah i mean
we do
hate to see it a full week after a short
week it's offensive
it's monday and this monday feels
particularly monday
particularly vile particularly toxic
particularly particular yeah
so we're just gonna power through you
know so much is going on we have so much
going on this week that's really
exciting
yes we have lots of lots of guests lots
of secret projects
lots of secret projects that you'll find
out about in like point two
yeah no we're just doing a bunch of
really good interviews this week so
we're super excited about that
we are and then also like you have a
really big life update to share with the
class
and um i do yeah i don't think that i do
it starts with the word see no i think
like if i tell you something
personal this is personal um it's like
stays between us
okay it's staying between us then yeah
do you want to start over
no no it's okay it's okay but like sorry
guys it's not even like a big deal
you're like
such a thing i just like decided to like
do something myself and like
it's not a big deal just like if i tell
you something personal like don't bring
it up on the show
i did not know that it was personal i
was i was looking forward to talking
about it but never mind it's really not
a big thing i was making it a bigger
thing than
no everyone's been like what is it now
like it's not a big deal like
just could move on please okay sure how
was your weekend it was good it was
filled with lots of highs and lows a low
was hosting shabbat at my home which was
very difficult for me
um but i did vlog the entire experience
on patreon so patreon.com morningtoast
shabbat at claudia's it was chaotic it
was messy
but in the end we turned it out no the
end i just watched the vlog it's up now
on patreon and the end was like
so beautiful it's it's a tale as old as
time a happy ending it was a happy
ending a delicious looking ending
and i was attended the shabbat and i can
say it was in fact delicious it was a
really nice you did a great job
thank you so much it was just like a lot
to spoil the vlog but it went really
well
yeah it's a lot to host but then also to
like make the choice to vlog it like
adds like another
burden element 100 um but then i wanted
to make the shabbat as good as possible
because i was vlogging
so in the end i think i was better off
because of the challenge the adversity
that i faced
um but it was a journey nonetheless and
then and now you have that content to
look back on
to laugh over yeah so it was really good
congratulations
fabulous fabulous thank you so much for
coming thank you for having me um
my weekend was really great i feel like
i did so much i was so productive
but also had a lot of fun was out and
about unfortunately
bruno was sick this weekend and it was
so
sad that's horrible it was so sad and
even this morning like he went into his
crate on his own
before it was time it's never good it's
not a good sign can i tell you something
like
so weird that happened to me this
morning speaking of bruno
i it's very hot in the city so i did
take an uber because it's just too hot
to like get all stunning and then like
become a sweat box and i really don't
feel like i need to explain myself yet
here i am explaining myself
i'm gonna get into the uber and the
driver is so sweet and he's like oh man
such a cute dog i'm like
theo he's like you know giving him this
whole like little elevator pitch yeah
he's a doctor
and then the uber driver said the
weirdest thing he's like
yeah i mean i was like gonna get a dog
but they just die after 10 years and i'm
like
excuse me i'm like why would you
say that i'm like oh i try not to think
about it he's like yeah no like
my dad had a dog and like he died and we
were all devastated so i was gonna get
one but then i'm just like dogs die i'm
like can you stop saying die
i was like yeah totally like i was
tearing up in the back of the car i just
didn't realize i was going to get into
an uber and
literally have my life ruined i just
didn't see that for myself no that's
wrong like obviously we all know that
that's the case but we all
i don't think that that's we all decide
that 10 years of love is worth
the pain that comes like grief is the
price that you pay for love so what
we're just not supposed to experience
love
no i i don't even
you don't even want to talk about it
yeah like i mean i did bring it up so
like
i didn't realize i realized that we
would have to talk about just responding
to your story your anecdote
i just like let's talk about how weird
it was like it was so rude
like yeah and you know what like with a
lit with modern medicine and a healthy
diet
10 plus 15. yeah it was just like so
abrasive i just wasn't expecting that
yeah no that's
that's wrong but you know it's a it's a
reminder that life is short
live it to the fullest life is short and
it's shorter for dogs oh stop okay this
is so upsetting
yeah sorry we're gonna we're gonna move
on again we're gonna pivot again
we just can't find a safe topic it's not
at all it's just like a landfill
mindful minefield but you know what
landmine what is a safe topic
always for us television and books yes
what did you read or watch this weekend
i finished why women kill um it's a
little annoying there are two things
about
i loved it and it was very like
reminiscent of desperate housewives i do
believe one of the houses on the street
in the first season
is catherine's house from desperate
house website it's definitely filmed on
wisteria lane
but one of the things i didn't like
about it was
first of all there's only a season and
like a half
on netflix i mean on paramount plus
maybe less and
two each season is a different story
so all the characters from the first
season who like you fell in love with
aren't in the second season it's like
we're starting fresh with like a whole
new
narrative which is cool but i really
like was obsessed with lucy lou's
character and there were just so many
like stories i loved following
they're over which is like annoying yeah
so i finished that um and then what i
i think that's all i watched i watched
the floyd mayweather fight which we're
going to talk about in our first story
which was
just really a historic event it was
really cool to be a part of something
it was you know how we feel like we're
just so excited to like you know know
what's going on and be included
yeah thanks for including us i watch
halston after your reviews on the show
did you finish it i finished it because
it was pretty short and i
enjoyed it because you know i finished
it but i just felt like i don't even
know that much about hallston but i know
enough to know that like that
documentary is like a grave injustice to
his name like
why just first of all the way that they
just went about everything sort of made
it seem like he
accidentally designed something amazing
or that everyone around him really like
propped him up and he
like he couldn't ever think of designs
when like in reality he totally changed
the face of american fashion
like that that person that was working
for him who accidentally tie-dyed some
stuff on his stove and then they made
and then they just cut a hole in the top
and made gowns like i just i think
it was a little more intentional than
that the documentary made it seem like
he literally
didn't have ideas of his own and wasn't
like the innovator
that he was i feel like in the beginning
definitely like it was going in that
direction but by the end of the show
like
respect was put on his name no it by the
end of it it just made it seem like he
finally realized you know
that he had made a lot of mistakes but
it was honestly too late to correct them
yeah but that might be how it actually
happened i'm sure that he made a lot of
mistakes and i'm sure you know some of
the
stuff i'm sure a lot of the stuff about
his work ethic and the drugs and
everything but in the beginning like
it just sort of seemed like he was
not that much of a visionary yeah but
when in reality
he was the visionary well let's let's
think about it because
some of the names that were being thrown
around as other like famous american
designers were like oscar de la renta
calvin klein at the time who were like
his competition yes
those names are still like huge names in
american fashion holstein really
isn't agreed but at the time yes
halston was the biggest one and he just
kind of didn't get that respect in the
show like if i didn't know anything
about houston
and now i feel like i need to go and do
research because no but i feel like
there's a like the reason
why disrespect was kind of put on his
story is because i feel like that's kind
of how it had to happen
because i don't know how you go from
being the calvin klein to being
in today there is like halston heritage
to being irrelevant
yeah but i think that's because he sold
his name the business of it all
yeah but also but i really was enjoying
the business of it all like
me too i was thinking like we needed
david mahoney up in here i know
i was like or whatever or do we i was
thinking like i didn't really feel like
he made that many bad decisions
in terms of selling the business david
maloney did
but i think like by the end they were
like i sold my name i sold my name
but they did great work and halston
himself was the one who ruined it in
addition to the bad business moves like
i don't really feel like the business
decisions that he made were so terrible
he became
the institute of american fashion
because he got bought
yeah i agree with that i didn't think it
was so bad either i was happy to like
see him doing well but of course you
know
there's a price for everything i just
feel like if i
now that i know he should have just done
jeans he should have just seen jeans but
now that i know even a little bit about
halston like i feel like
that show is like a disservice to his
memory and i need to take it upon myself
to do a little more research i do not
feel like that is a full
and fair picture can i tell you that i
accidentally watched an amazon prime
documentary
on um
on hallston when i thought i was
watching like the show that everyone was
talking about
and i only watched the first hour i
think was like a two-hour documentary
but then when i watched the hallston
series
i like knew a lot of what they were
referring to like the documentary on
amazon prime i think
you might find more educational did tell
a lot of the same story that the netflix
show did yeah i think i
i'm gonna have to do a little bit more
researching you know when you're
watching like someone's life story you
shouldn't leave feeling that way so
overall like i enjoyed it it was
enjoyable but i just
did you think you and mcgregor was good
no i didn't mean he didn't like bother
me as much as he bothered you except
towards the end
but no i i didn't think he was great me
neither
so but a little fun fact i did not know
like he did the pillbox hat you know
yeah and in the documentary on prime
they had like a little fun fact like
jackie
when she was like walking out of the
limo at the inauguration she touched the
back of her
the back of the hat and dented the hat
so everyone thought it was like a
fashion choice but it was really just
like she dented it
oh that's so interesting yeah okay yeah
that's the sort of stuff that i wanted
yeah you would like the prime
documentary it was like very
artistically done honestly the
the style of how they did the
documentary was bothering the [ __ ] out
of me and i'm like this is what everyone
is obsessed with but then i realized i
was watching the wrong show
got it so anyways glad i watched it um
it was nice to you know be watching tv
again but then i went back to reading
and i'm reading this book called the
woman before wallace
wallace simpson you know who she is um
so it was like the woman that um
edward was in love with before wallace
and she has to like go so she was
actually
um gloria vanderbilt's twin sister oh
wow and she had too
anderson cooper of it all she had to go
back to um
the us because of the custody trial
which was a really big deal
and i think it was in that time due to
the trial that wallace wooed her man's
got it but i'm not spoiler alert also
i'm not that far along it i don't know
if that's what happens it just seems
that way i didn't read anything this
weekend i just like i had a really good
balance of like peacefulness
and like i ended up at a rave on
saturday night and four in the morning
like at a townhouse and it was
incredibly bizarre but super fun
no i agree i had a good balance of
peacefulness and out and aboutness and
socialization and also i didn't start
malibu rising because i'm going to wait
till i'm
on a beach i i think it's like such a
great b treat and i'm really saving it
okay
so that's that on that that's not on
that i think we should dive in because
we've got a big story and i'm just dying
to talk about this fight that happened
last night because it was
truly remarkable oh so should i bump
that up to number one
oh is it not number one you lose the
number two lily bet lily bed is number
one lily bed is number one there's so
much to talk about we have to go so
without further ado
where are you right here being perfect
it is time for the past life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode of the morning toast
is brought to you by pura veda
summer is almost upon us is your
wardrobe ready what better way to get
back into the carefree spirit of summer
than with
a brand whose apparel and accessories
are all about a laid-back
living and enjoying life to the fullest
pura vida's fair trade apparel and
artisan made accessories are comfortable
casual eco-friendly and just so cool
perfect in time for summer their jewelry
is like
so like i'm just such a cool girl like
hanging in montauk like my hair dries
naturally wavy like
if you're looking for that aesthetic for
the summer at the beach at the clubs
wherever you're going on vacation
pura vita has you covered from top to
bottom they have colorful colorful
graphic tees cropped t-shirts and
hoodies
including one-of-a-kind tie dyes that
are fun to wear and express your
personality
they have over 200 styles in the summer
catalog all their products are buttery
soft and 100 cotton apparel
so working from home has never been
comfier the styles are super affordable
with bracelets starting at six dollars
and rings starting at 12
um if you like to mix your jewelry and
like stack rings this is a perfect place
you can get a bunch for a really
affordable price and they're super good
quality
they're really known for their beautiful
handmade braided bracelets that are
unisex fully adjustable
and 100 waterproof so you can live in
them 24 7.
pura vita look good and do good to get
20 off your pure vita
order text toast to 38817
that's toast to three eight eight one
seven to get twenty percent off at pura
vita term supply available at pura
vitabracelets.com
terms text toast to 38817 you'll get a
free sticker with every order
love it okay first story big news of the
weekend well
two big stories first story is that
meghan markle and prince harry welcome a
baby girl
named for both the queen and princess
diana
they announced it is with great joy that
prince harry and megan the duke and
duchess of sussex welcomed their
daughter
lily bett lily diana mountbound and
windsor to the world
lily was born on friday june 4th at 11
40 a.m in the trusted care of the
doctors and staff at santa barbara
cottage hospital in santa barbara
california
santa barbara she weighed seven pounds
11 ounces
both mother and child are healthy and
well and settling in at home
so lily is named after her
great-grandmother her majesty the queen
whose family nickname is lillabet if you
watch the queen
if you watch the crown that is no
surprise her middle name diana was
chosen to honor her beloved late
grandmother the princess of wales
though spencer was in consideration for
the first name the couple decided
last minute not t no you're lying oh my
god i just got so excited okay
before we dive in because i do have some
thoughts mostly negative um
i just want to say i do think it's very
weird that like everyone gets an opinion
on like what someone names their baby
but of course these are like ex-royal
figures
so that is what we do but i just want to
say like it does feel bizarre like it's
their choice it's their family it's
their baby like let them do it
100 but it's not even just them like
even with celebrities we're
oh yeah this has historical significance
therefore i feel it's like i can have an
opinion
on it yes but it does feel weird like to
comment on like a personal choice you
know no and also i feel like
even when they had archie it wasn't as
big of a deal
a deal just what they were gonna name it
because it's like are they gonna
hark back to the royals are they not no
but like when you're a part of the royal
institution there's only a certain
amount of names you're like legally
allowed to choose from so like it's not
a surprise it's like george arthur or
alexander like you know like yeah yeah
they're all the same but now that
they're out of it
they could choose you know sarah or they
could they could get more creative with
it and i do think it's very interesting
that
first of all they didn't choose to honor
prince philip's memory like we had
spoken about
the toasters i'm so sorry it didn't
happen it didn't happen for you um that
they didn't
honestly like in first name decide to
honor diana because i just feel like
like harry's obsessed like with his
mother's legacy like as he should be
um i feel like he talks about it a lot
and yes it's obviously like a tragic
loss
and she's not alive anymore but like the
queen is so like i just thought it was
weird that he chose to honor the queen
first diana ii
i also obviously thought it was weird
that like literally they're coming off
this interview like disgracing the
family
and like this just seems like kind of
kiss assy like oh we like to love our
grandmother so much like we're just
gonna name it after her you know
yeah i just want to know like there's so
many reports that like the queen is
furious the queen gave approval
what does the queen think like i want to
know because it's hard because for
us commoners we're just going off of the
things that we actually know which is
that
the you know the oprah interview and now
the kid's name is lillabet and it's like
these two things
seem in conflict with one another one
plus one equals sock like
one plus one equals sock and so to me
i'm just like
confused and i love the name lily and i
i that's what they're gonna
call her but it you know it lilabet is
the larger name i just feel like lilabet
like is her family nickname it's just
like so personal
yeah to the queen and i don't know i
it does seem weird it seems like an
invasion of privacy like
like first of all nobody goes out in the
streets and calls her hate a little bit
like everyone calls her queen elizabeth
and i think it was like a name that
prince philip like chose for so it's
like a sweet like
endearing personal things so it is kind
of weird to like put it on blast well i
think they were calling her since she's
a kid
and so not prince fella but yeah yeah it
was it's just a very personal name so
i don't know i i like the name lily for
her that's what they're gonna call her
i just i don't know
also someone sent me the funniest dm
because people like
who are reading it who don't watch that
who don't know that lillabet is
elizabeth
they're like a little bit yeah no it
sounds like a rapper and then someone's
messaged me they're like it reminds me
of a little bit of lexus a little bit
alexis
a little bit diana that's so funny
and now i can't get that out of my head
no 100 it's also just like not
i think a very common american name i
think people in the uk are like familiar
with that nickname for elizabeth
um i hadn't you know ever heard of it
before the queen
so it's like original and stuff i don't
know i'm just like i'm just confused
like i need more of clarity on like how
we got from
disgracing the royal family in a
interviewing like exposing all their
dirty secrets
to honor yourself in really every public
way and making it very clear where you
stand
and even though they they didn't really
take jabs at the queen
they're jabbing her life's work right
her dad's life's work her entire
life like ancestral life's work
and so i just think it's um
it's just how did we get from a to b
like i would just like some clarity
and maybe there's things that are
happening behind the scenes that we
do not know but once again we only know
what we know and so just like from the
interview to the name it's
it's um it's a hop skip and a jump like
yeah i'm just confused so
it's lily diana is very pretty i was
just shocked at a few
of the elements i thought for sure the
name was going to be like a direct
diana diana moment but it was the middle
name which is like
irrelevant yeah that's just like
something that you do to be nice to be
nice
yeah and it's because she has a long
name now lil about diana mountbatten
windsor
yeah lilly lillabet diana mountbatten
wizard lillabet lilly in windsor
it's a lot of names yeah but
congratulations to
the happy family and we just love some
we love some ben news and i like that
like nobody was able to guess it like
that's cool you know we're all just
surprised
yeah the people this is like when i when
i first heard the
um the name i was like
of course shocked because i didn't think
that's what it was gonna be but also
like all these royal experts who've like
literally never been right about
anything that's why how are we supposed
to believe like any of these reports
when the royal exports said the name was
going to be philippa 100
so it's like what do we we don't know
anything like we we're clowns over here
thinking we know what the [ __ ] going
on right but at least we knew it wasn't
going to be phillip
yeah because we're not dumb because we
knew that much at least yes
okay we're ready for our next story the
big news of the weekend logan paul goes
the distance with floyd
mother mayweather i love florida my
mother
floyd mayweather in exhibition bout so
pay-per-view last night logan paul
versus floyd mayweather he stood the
eight rounds there was no knockout
yeah i mean it was like truly impressive
i feel like the kind of
like the narrative like i was watching i
bought it on showtime and
the mcs were um
like the regular mc like i don't know
his name and then jesus and maro like
the comedy duo
and like the whole time they were just
like clown like he's lasting longer than
a tick tock there were so many tick-tock
jokes honestly it was some of the least
creative jokes i've ever heard in my
life
um everyone's just like clowning on him
because he's like a social media
sensation and everyone's just like
joking making a joke out of it
but i honestly like i watched it and i
was like i'm sorry like you have to give
credit where credit is due
he didn't get knocked out he lasted all
eight rounds of course by the eighth
round like floyd member hadn't even
broken a sweat
and logan paul looked like he was
literally about to faint like walking
out of
the competition into their locker rooms
like floyd mayweather looks like he
literally had went for a walk in the
park
and logan paul looked like he had been
kidnapped for a month like
of course but he did it like and i don't
know i just feel like all these jokes
whatever like say what you want but like
logan paul like actually did that he
didn't get knocked out
he got like a couple good punches and of
course floyd's numbers like in
statistics were of course
way better than logan's but i'm sorry
like you have to he held his own
he did and like even floyd mayweather
said in the post fight interview like he
was way better than i thought he was
going to be and like he's a decent
fighter and like this is just the
beginning of
something great so you know what and
then logan paul said i was kind of
inspired he was like
nothing's impossible like look at me
like i literally made vines and i just
fought the best fighter in arguably in
history
yeah that's good do you think that floyd
mayweather was holding back
okay so like now there are all these
conspiracy theories because like floyd
mayweather got 90
of the bag so however many people bought
pay-per-view on all these different
platforms
he got 90 of sales and logan paul agreed
to only take 10 just so he could fight
floyd mayweather
um so and even in these pre-interview
packages they were putting together get
to know the fighters like
floyd mayweather mayweather like i don't
know
floyd it's a mouthful floyd mayweather
made it very clear like
of course he loves boxing but like his
passion is investing and building
generational wealth for his family so
like
he was he owns like gentlemen's clubs he
owns construction companies
real estate portfolios like so he's
really all about the money and so
it makes me think like did he only take
this fight and like agree to like go all
the way around just like make the most
possible money the longer the fight is
on the more people buy it like but he
could have like let loose in the eighth
round yeah and also
i kept saying to ben like he has
integrity as a fighter now this was an
exhibition which means it doesn't go in
the record books
floyd mayweather's 50 and 0. he's not
51-0 now
there was no real winner um unless
someone got knocked out but i think they
both agreed that they weren't gonna
knock out like
so it's kind of like a pointless fight
um because it doesn't have any real
bearing on and there's no usually
there's like a council who decides if
nobody gets knocked out like who got the
most punches like
someone will decide who wins and you
know they hold up the hand in the middle
of the ring yeah there was none of that
so like it was kind of pointless they
both just like made a ton of money for
like no reason
well i think they put on the show yeah
and they brought people together
the amigos performed there was a there
was a full card there was a fight before
um so it was like a whole thing yeah no
i think it was pretty cool
i didn't watch the entire thing but i
watched the first two rounds i think
plus zach
called me to come out when logan paul
came out to from now on from the
greatest showman that was crazy which
was just
really i didn't think logan paul man of
taste i just didn't see that for him and
i have a whole new respect
yeah i actually had like a whole new
respect for logan paul the whole evening
from i know people don't like him
and of course he's problematic in his
own way with the whole cancellation but
i really feel like
the logan we're seeing now is a totally
different constantly evolving
he is and i just really like appreciated
even though like they're so chaotic like
whatever happened with the fbi at jake
paul's house like we'll literally never
know
they're so supportive of one another
like yeah you can't help but like really
respect their brotherly relationship
like jake paul is like tweeting
my brother beat floyd mayweather he
didn't like if there was a winner it
would have been floyd mayweather
um no and even you saw jake pawlik when
they would pander him and he was just
like going
so hard it was sweet i'm sorry like i
don't know if i was the only one like
you could now but like really think like
look what these two morons did like
literally from ohio
you know made their bones off of eating
legos and you know beating up
each other in their living room and like
they're on the biggest stage in the
world and i'm sorry like there is
something impressive about that
i agree regardless of whether or not you
like like them or or their content and
i've literally never seen a piece of
their content in my life like i don't
follow them
i'm don't buy maverick apparel but there
is something to be said about
you why maverick apparel why you don't
want to accept ben
no i don't like i'm saying i'm not like
a fan of theirs but like i don't know it
was also just like bothering me how like
all the announcers was like you know
you're hating this if you're
normal but loving it if you're an 11
year old it's just like this constant
like
beratement and like mocking of like
people on the internet which i didn't
really appreciate but i was really
i was proud to be an influencer last
night yeah so logan fought recently
right
like jake did okay that was my question
who did he fight
jake fought nate robinson who's a
retired nba player and
knocked him out in the first round oh
wow so like
and but there are all these conspiracy
theories that like because there's so
much money in boxing like
these people are going to agree to
anything to get knocked out like if they
so you just put on a show all these
people think that like it's staged or
it's
you know scripted almost but
i watched knockout it looked pretty real
yeah interesting
lamar odom saying he wants to fight
logan paul like oh cool
logan and jake should fight each other
100
that's a good call yeah free idea but
this one was like a
re like a very legit it was showtime it
was extremely legit it was extremely
legit whereas like the jake paul one was
super legit too but it was like on
triller sponsored by triller trailer
trailer trailer tick-tock tick you know
like
yeah so it is what it is yeah no i
understand
and i had one other thought about it
which was
something that has escaped me so
obviously it obviously wasn't that
important
obviously was not that oh just um like
floyd mayweather um repping tmt we just
want to thank you so much for that
for sponsoring our brand and um and your
belief in us it's really stunning to see
yeah we do love to see it thank you yeah
i also just like actually
ended up with like a lot of respect for
floyd mayweather too because
first of all he could have like joined
in on like everyone the whole night
everyone was making fun of logan paul
like from the announcers on social media
like everyone it was like joke joke joke
but in the pre post interview and even
in the pre-interview like little package
he said he has a lot of respect
for what logan paul has done where he's
gotten himself and
after he was like he was much better
than i thought and i had a lot of fun
nice
so it was like you know it was a fun
sportsmanship fun sunday night
activities
people at the hard rock stadium looked
like they were having fun i'm having fun
we're all just having fun yeah they're
putting on the show you know after a
whole year of like
no entertainment i'm here for it and i
probably like before the before covered
like never would have watched paid 50
for that piece of [ __ ] but after my bar
is so low it was fabulous
speaking of after speaking of
after okay literally you guys are not
not to make the fight about me but i
have no choice it was made about me
after the fight was over they were doing
like all these you know like recaps and
shmeet caps and post-op
i turned it off and went to bed and
right before i went to bed
my phone is like lighting up margo's
calling me i have all these text
messages people are tagging me in all
these stories
after the fight ended my comedy special
came on my comedy special is available
on paper
pay-per-view so i guess it was like
promo but i was like
are you kidding me like am i the most
famous person in the world you know how
many people were watching that yeah how
many people like couldn't find their
remotes or just like were you know
drinking and like left it on when they
were like a party yeah all of a sudden
claudia
ashrae it was so crazy and like honestly
i was i couldn't sleep after that the
weirdest [ __ ] happens to me like
literally that is so
funny i know i mean i hope that so many
people watch it and had a great laugh
um and also cream means creme
yeah they probably learned a lot also my
comedy special is available to free
for free to stream on amazon prime it's
called claudia austria disgraced queen
it's about an hour it's free so there's
no reason you can't watch it
love it and leave a five star review oh
100 we love five star reviews are you
ready for our next
story yeah i am only if it's a story
that's brought to you by hair food is
there is there a chance
there is a big chance huge hair food
offers simple superfood inspired
products that will make your hair look
and feel amazing
whatever hair texture or hair type you
have hair food has a recipe for you
in addition to their beloved nourishing
coconut milk and chai spice collection
you've got to try some of their new
recipes the apple cider vinegar hair
rinse which is perfect for days when
your hair needs a gentle gentle cleanse
before conditioning the turmeric and
almond oil detangling milk which is my
favorite product
takes care of the most stubborn knots
and it reduces frizz detanglers they're
not just for kids you guys we could all
use a little detangler especially after
the beach
the shea butter and pear color repair
concentrate so if you color your hair
this product makes over-processed hair
look vibrant and healthy
all the products smell so good and they
are free of sulfates parabens dyes
mineral oils
and they are certified peda cruelty free
if you're looking for nourished healthy
hair it's got to be hair food
look for it at amazon walmart and target
you'll see amazing results whether your
hair is dry naughty frizzy over
processed
there's a product at hair food for you
and it's all available at amazon walmart
and target
love it i just want to say i just saw an
article in the sidebar about the the
lillabet name and you are right that it
was bestowed upon her by her late
husband prince philip so it's an
intimate thing
that feels like it's being exploited
unless elizabeth is okay with it i just
need the queens
we're never gonna get it so like we
could all be morons and like you know
fight amongst ourselves
but like until i know what the queen is
thinking i feel like it's a slight
right but harry's people said they got
express written permission
from the queen but then also i read
reports the queen was furious like in
the daily mail right what
is true right and also this royal expert
another one oh another
what's her name angela levin no not her
melanie bromley yeah just because you're
british doesn't mean you're a writer
okay but this royal expert said that she
doesn't think the name was a good idea i
think it's quite rude to her majesty her
queen
it was a very private nickname from her
husband who hasn't been dead very long
prince charles would never dream of
calling his mother a little bit
oh he wouldn't no no it was like an
intimate thing yeah that's like okay
ben calls me movie that's like literally
you naming your kid
no but like we don't have beef right no
and then we had me
i didn't do an interview about you yeah
i don't know i just like i can't decide
what megan and harry want from the royal
family like
because it seems like they
hate them but love them like which one
is it no no it's it's really
quite and i know it's not about me but i
am confused like i would love some
clarity
i'm you know what i feel like they're
like i feel like the royals are confused
too they're like wait
what do you hate us do you love us do
you want do you want in you want yeah
it's confusing yeah like you would but
literally it's pretty anyways i just
wanted to share that because you were
right and i said and i just want to
correct that
it's so rare you know you were right
thank you also i'm still waiting for
you were right about the olivia rodrigo
not being a one-hit wonder but you won't
give me that by the way that's not the
argument the argument was i was saying
it's too
it's too early to say whether or not
she's a one-hit wonder okay but the
initial argument was you said like she
no could be a one-wonder oh yeah i said
that she could be because she could and
i said it was already decided that she
wasn't like after and
it was too early to make the decision
okay i think you're wrong no but i just
i do want to clear that up because i
think very well she probably won't be a
one-hit wonder i was just saying it's
too early to call it
it seems like you're backtracking now
nope roll the tapes
roll the tape seems like you're back you
heard what you wanted to hear you heard
what you wanted to hear it's all there
for you
it's all there for you guys to listen to
it who has the memory here
me okay now we can get into our next
story mariah carey is dumping jay-z's
rock nation after a blazing row
i love like this is like some hollywood
biz industry news it's interesting when
people like leave their agencies or
their
record deals yeah and in a blaze of
glory too
the uber diva has parted ways with jay-z
and his management company roc nation
after a blazing row with the rapper
during a meeting about the future of her
career according to the sun
carrie signed with jay-z in 2017 years
after firing her former manager
stella bulachiknov and there's a lot of
drama there there's lawsuits on both
sides there
mariah and jay had an explosive meeting
which did not go well at all a source
close to the
situation told the sun she has made it
clear she wants nothing more to do with
him and has called it quits with roc
nation
she will formally depart in the next few
weeks it is a shame because they had
done some great work in the last few
years but this meeting couldn't have
gone much worse
mariah has been talking to other
managers and thinks she has found
someone who she feels has full belief in
her as she takes her next steps
i mean it's i don't know what mariah
carey like would want for her career
because she's kind of in this like
ethereal place where she's just like a
legend
she's not releasing bops left right and
center but like her
story her book was hugely popular her
catalog of music is hugely popular
her you know christmas you know she
comes live at christmas like i actually
feel like she's been doing a pretty good
job for the last few years like rock
nation wasn't doing a bad job
yeah her social media is great like
whoever runs
her social like she's in on the joke you
know yeah she comes alive after
thanksgiving like it's all very funny it
is very funny and i feel like they got
her to a really good place
after the other manager of like this is
like you know with the book and the
christmas and like this is who you are
but like
they packaged her up very well still the
future is
in question what will she do next and
it's clear that they didn't agree
yeah that's true but also i feel like we
kind of forget like there was like a
dark mariah carry time like remember
when she performed at
um the christmas lighting tree tree
lighting and like literally
somebody like her vocals were atrocious
we forgot about that like somebody
really scooped her up i think roc nation
actually did a pretty good job
i'm curious like what mariah carey wants
for her future well after reading her
book i feel like she wants to keep
making music i know like she's not
releasing pop after bop but like music
was so it's such a part of her like in
the book she can't stop like just
because you
hit a certain age doesn't mean you're
done living like you're not at all i
just feel like mariah carey like
literally
hasn't had a song that i know in like 10
years maybe more
yeah no but i think that she would blame
her managers
yeah but she's only been with roc nation
for the last four years but where's the
song that you know
you know right no that's true she's just
not like a radio artist anymore and i
don't know if that's what she wants to
be because she's kind of
she's in a place most artists would
dream of like eternal icon status
and those people don't always like
release bots like but i think the music
flows out of her and she wants to be at
a place that's gonna
allow her to create new music and also
fully support the music
yeah and not just work on like emerging
artists i don't know nothing was a
management company i thought it was a
record label i know i agree
not that i think that's what's happening
i just really think she would want like
she wants to keep putting out albums
but maybe she's just not getting like
maybe a r's not giving her the best
songs that's possible the writing writer
she writes her own songs so
i don't know yeah i feel like she can
really um get into like a place where
she's
you know somebody adapts her book into a
movie like kind of how like
like she was in glitter should we need
like a glitter about mariah carey
yeah and i'm sure that's probably in the
works but she probably still wants to be
making music like
the bops she wants the bops yeah for
sure but that's very interesting you
know
i love a little biz news industry
business okay
next story a little insider news
bachelor stars matt james and rachel
corconnell are planning to move in
together
so things are finally going well between
matt and rachel
story no it's not it's the fourth and
second to last story the pent ultimate
story
the that's an sat word the big peak
before the fifth what'd you get on that
sages
a really good score of
um out of 2 400 yeah i got a 20 40.
wow that's crazy i got a 17. i was
thinking the other day like i asked ben
i'm like i never know what he got on his
sats
um he couldn't remember but he was like
something average and i'm like yeah i
think i did look really bad
no i did pretty good um i worked really
hard for
like studying and stuff yeah so did i
yeah because like my grades were like
i had pretty good grades but like the
sats were just
they did you in they they're just not
for me you know and i was like on the
precipice of people taking the acts
which is a much more
apt test like the sats don't test how
smart you are it's like how much can we
trick you it's the dumbest thing ever
yeah no i hear that that now everyone
takes the acts
yes yeah but these days are just like
learning differently
yeah and it's also like annoying because
everyone talks about the sats like 1600
and it's like no it hasn't been 1600 for
so long like what did you get out of
2400 yeah
because i can't i can't relate to you
totally i can't compare myself to you
because
i only know my 2400 score totally but it
is cool how they do the super scores
what's up where like if you take the
test twice they'll use your best score
from each well
you know it's like they're trying to
lift the kids up not tear them down
i grew up in an age where literally the
education board of education was trying
to put me down no no you grew up in the
super square age just want to let you
know
i'm just letting you know like i was
right on the cusp like there was like a
few kids who took the acts in my grade
and it was like the weird thing to do
like it wasn't the norm
yes no i agree with you but i'm just
saying you when you took the sats like
the 17
score was your best in all categories
for how many times you took it oh i got
a super score
yeah oh then maybe i did better than
1790 because that doesn't track
yeah yeah yeah yeah not that dumb
anyways man reach are moving in together
they're thinking about where they want
to move they're thinking about where he
wants to restart his real estate
they've been gallivanting all over the
hamptons being socialites in the city
in the hamptons double dating in the
hamptons with tyler c yeah his leading
lady
i don't know how i feel about them about
what about who
rachel madden them as a couple i liked
them a lot and then like they had this
really public
awkward like thing to deal with and now
they're just like back to normal and i'm
like
it's like it's like a megan and harry
thing like what am i missing like how
did we get from a to b
okay now that like they're so full steam
ahead they're moving in together it
seems a little early but not if they've
been together this whole time do you
think that they
always knew that they were going to get
back together no
it was so real like people are saying
like was that stage
it was so real and so raw and so awkward
like for us like
i don't think you they're not actors
like i don't think you can fake that
like i think that was very real right
but then how can you
go from that to this i don't know this
is what i'm saying there is a piece
missing
just like little bit how do we go from
oprah to a little bit how do we go from
after the final rows to you know riding
in a side car in manhattan together
yeah yeah and moving in together they're
saying he's going to move to miami
but where's she from she's from georgia
yeah but i see them living in new york i
don't know why i just feel like they're
always here they're like
there's like a lot of bachelor this
season girls who live in new york like
they're always hanging out together
yes they are like the pipers of the
world and chelsea
yeah there's like a cool like social
like crew i didn't see that for the
season no i didn't but i'm happy to see
it like it's
people usually don't move to new york
yeah um they move to l.a
yeah or they'll move to like dallas
chicago whatever and so it's cute to see
all the girls like here
the new season of the bachelorette is
starting tonight katie thurston's season
i can't wait to continue reading my book
tonight i can't wait like
it's so terrible but like you know you
just like hope other people fail
like i'm just hoping this bachelor like
i hope that the season
does poorly like ratings wise because
like this is what you get for giving us
literally
the last thing we asked for nobody was
championing there was no campaign
there was nothing like give us katie we
need the deal
nobody asked for that we need the dildo
there was an
outcry for michelle and maybe the
ratings will bounce back but i just want
you to know like this is what
you get when you don't give us what we
want and you just like throw a bunch of
[ __ ] at the wall and hope something
sticks
yes so you won't be watching tonight
that's what you're saying no i'll
definitely be watching no i'm kidding
um i i have to you know it's a really
tough like internal thing to struggle
with
because if i didn't do this for a living
there's i would have stopped watching
years ago but you know it's so great for
you know for
content and for viewership and my
stories like i'd love to be like i claim
to be like this
we claim to be the center of all things
pop culture and the bachelor
unfortunately is a part of that
but i think for my own mental well-being
and just like
protecting myself from outside negative
forces that are toxic to me
i i have to move on i do and we have a
literal tnn show
called the snatcher devoted to recapping
the bachelor so it's good for business
i just like listen to the snatcher she's
going to be everything you need the
correspondent for the bachelorette the
season
i just can't do it yeah it's in
satchel's hands now yeah
and i do think i know i always say this
i think it's the end of
the franchise for me permanently and
that just pains me because it's a big
part of our job
yeah bye bye are you ready for our fifth
and final story
only if it's the fifth and finals oh
whoa actually
that that flying is the perfect segue
for our for the final story is it an
aviation story
it's a little space news oh yes well
today's space news is brought to you
by tick tock for you welcome to the
first official for you
tick tock podcast hosted hosted by
creator brittany brosky
we live for her they discuss everything
tick-tock with creators who have turned
the platform into a global community and
cultural phenomenon
this podcast really is for you whether
you're you're a creator or just
interested in the world of tick tock
join them for never before heard stories
and insights from those who create
videos
and culture on tik tok you can preview
uh the tick tock free podcast on tick
tock live every wednesday at 5 30 p.m
pacific time
which is 8 30 p.m central time the host
and top tick tock creator brittany
broski
has hilarious and warm-hearted
conversations about the world of
tick-tock with those who know it best
past guests have included frankie jonas
bowman martinez reid lauren gray
love her and youngblood you can listen
to the tic toc for you podcast anywhere
you get your podcast again
you can watch it live um on
tick tock live every wednesday at 5 30
p.m pacific 8 30 pm central
and then anywhere you get your podcast
you can get the tick tock for you
podcast with brittany broski it's
she's so funny it's such a good podcast
check it out love it okay fifth and
final story
it's the final story
we should record that so that we have it
and even though i like to do it like
it gets me in the mood it gets me going
yeah it gets the people going
jeff bezos is traveling to space with
his brother in july he said this is the
greatest adventure with my best friend
that is so
sweet no it's not jeff bezos this is one
this is like an annoying rich people
thing like i'm annoyed with just you're
gonna be more annoyed when i get
when i finish reading the deets like you
know like astronauts literally trained
their whole life to go to space and like
you have literally no formal training
jeff bezos is preparing to go out of
this world blue origin the aerospace
manufacturing and space flight company
founded by jeff bezos
oh he's trying to compete and his
brother oh yeah he's been trying to
compete for a while and his brother mark
are
preparing no yeah
founded by jeff bezos announced that
jeff bezos and his brother
are preparing to fly to space on july
20th on new shepard's first human flight
they will also bring along the winner of
an auction who paid 2.8 million dollars
to also be on this flight
hitting me wait jeff said ever since i
was five years old i've dreamed of
traveling to space on july 20th
i will take that journey that's not like
a unique thought like all kids want to
be astronauts like i just want to say
like
this just make you special on july 20th
i will take that journey with my brother
the greatest adventure with my best
friend
i mean we can respect siblings who um no
but even
that sibling element like can't make me
hate this story even less
no you're about to oh there's more
according to the official website the
new because when you think you're going
to space it's like okay like let's get
our space food like
we're going on a vacation to space
according to the official website the
new shepard seats six astronauts and
since the ship is fully autonomous
there's no pilot everyone is a passenger
the reusable vehicle takes
11 minute flights into space designed to
take astronauts and research payloads
past the carm online which is the
internationally recognized boundary of
space
so this is an eleven like going on the
moon
flight got it okay like this is
obviously
a little dramatic yeah this is obviously
a like big pr stunt for his like fake
spacex company that i've never [ __ ]
heard of
um and this is kind of like once again
really illusory of jeff bezos
and i have come to ev with every story
we talk about whether it was those text
messages
i want to get drunk with you not too
drunk then i want to wake up and read
the newspaper with you
like whether it was that or the whole
drama with the national enquirer and
that girl and her brother
or now this spacex he himself
i've come to the conclusion i need my
gavel is a loser
he is he's like a kind of like a dope
yeah for sure and like i feel like
whenever we talk about amazon
people don't really like what i have to
say because they're constantly like
putting down small businesses but they
really are great for the consumer like
for i use amazon prime grocery i
literally use it all
when it comes to amazon i'm on team
amazon when it comes to jeff bezos
he's a [ __ ] loser yeah for sure and
this is just like so obvious like
everyone's always comparing him to elon
musk
now he's obviously trying to compete
with elon musk like stay in your lane
like
you own amazon you like on the
washington post weirdly like you do your
own thing like leave us alone
yeah you stay on earth elon will stay in
space yeah like elon's got it
covered no he's got it covered like
honestly like nasa has it covered and
then elon musk is just like even
more like nasa works with elon yeah i'm
not like
this this kind of brings it back to i
don't know if anyone has been listening
to our show from the morning breath days
we kind of had this was what was the
morning breath 2017
we kind of had this fascination with
elon musk who was like being spoken
about a lot for like making cars but
then also going to space and like
we kind of went on this rant and this is
how we like initially became obsessed
with him because like we were like what
do you even do bro like yeah
you do go to space and it turns out like
he really does do both and also now he
does like tunnels too hyperloop all
sorts of transportation right so like
the person we thought he was is like
exactly who he is you know
and i feel like he's really carved out
of space for himself being like
billionaire but also like the albert
einstein people say of our generation
go albert so i just think like jeff
bezos is kind of jealous of the space
elon musk has carved out for himself
because jeff bezos i think what people
think of like classic
like you know person with too much money
like jeff bezos is kind of like the butt
of that joke
people don't always like loop in elon
musk with that because elon musk is like
a true genius
yeah but he's also new to the
billionaires like to the to the number
one
list scene yeah so i love when we just
go down a rabbit hole of like forbes
list and then we just like you know
yeah look for all the eligible men on
the list yeah no it's always a good time
it's always fun
but jeff bezos is going to space in july
with his barely
barely 11 minutes like is i didn't
realize that's just not what i thought
of when i when you think of going
i think you'd like chill up there like
for a couple weeks they're going yeah
right but they're just going to cross
the line of the stratosphere and then
come back down
do you remember that there is an
internationally recognized line for what
constitutes space and earth right do you
remember when that guy
that like stunt man went up like and
shoot it off red bull yeah parachuted
off like a a spaceship
like outside the earth's yeah like he
was looking down at earth that was crazy
he like went in and out of consciousness
but he's like still alive and fine
that's so crazy that was like no offense
like the dumbest thing ever like
i don't understand people who just like
test god that way like i agree but it
was a really cool video
when i went on the sea plane i was like
thinking to myself like i'm one of those
morons who tests
no you're like one of those red bill
people like yeah like hold a little
eddie
total um that's our show we have no tv
recap tomorrow
um we have no tv recap either but there
is
a episode of the snapshot coming out so
you'll be able to listen to the bachelor
recap bachelorette excuse me recap there
i'll be taking the night off you know
soaking in the tub you know enjoying
myself maybe i'll make myself some
dinner like
living myself give myself peace of mind
yes
definitely it's going to be a great week
you guys yes we have
i'm like afraid to say we have a great
guest tomorrow i know the minute that we
say that we have guests coming
even if we say the word guest then
there's a cancel
magically disappear so we've got a great
guest tomorrow and a great guest
wednesday hopefully they both show up
yeah so that's sad on that thank you
guys so much for listening to the
morning toast the millennium morning
show where we deliver the facts back
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so it's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i got rid of cats
box all the places
wherever you listen to podcasts find us
leave a five star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you guys have an amazing day we'll see
you tomorrow
[Music]
goodbye